welcome to opengl
episode 11 here on code tech tutorials
my name is matt and today we're going to
go over
just the basics of getting started out
with texturing and adding those to our
shaders
and we're going to take the little side
scroller game where we've just been
using colored
planes and change those into textured
planes and i'm going to walk through all
that now obviously i'm not going to
cover
every single thing about textures there
is so i'm going to drop some references
in case you want to look at more and we
will do more episodes about this in the
future
on things like cube maps and once we get
to i guess
shadows and reflections we can talk more
about that too but that sort of involves
some advanced texturing topics and of
course it also just depends on what
you're working on because
there's a lot of uses of textures
there's so much you can do with them
let's
see what it takes to make the basics of
a textured cube let me go ahead and run
this
we'll see you get uh we get
approximately what we had before except
now it's all textured up and we see some
odd stretching in the center there but
these ones over here look decently tiled
so that's not too bad there is a little
bit of stretching on them as well but
you can't really tell
so yeah our little game still works and
now you can really tell
the shapes of things like how this was
built based on the textures and if we
fall off can really see how the x was
built with just a couple
planes i also moved some of the code
around i basically took all the cursor
code and put it into a single file
and that way it could just be called as
necessary with just a setup and an
update
and a render so with those basic
functions we can just call those in our
main loop
as necessary just like we were doing
with the side scroller
and handle all that just abstract it out
because there's no reason to have all
the cursor stuff convoluting this
every time okay well so we want to get
textures loading and we're going to do
this in our site scroller
within our site scroller program so it's
all going to be done within the setup
but you're also going to notice that
we're going to basically add some
rendering support for this sort of thing
so you'll see in here texture loader
which actually might have been in here
last episode too but we weren't
quite using it yet so all this basically
does is it takes the data from a texture
and uploads it to your graphics card and
it returns an unsigned int which is
going to be the way
to reference it on your graphics card so
that's the first thing to do is just get
the texture data
and upload it to your graphics card
there are some specifications here
and i'm not going to talk about them a
ton but you can go look them up because
this just it would be a lot
i'll drop some references down below to
talk about them
and if there's a lot of confusion i'll
do an episode on just these
so you basically need to set your
texture parameters to how you want it to
be
the clamp to edge is what is stretching
it to the edges
there are other settings here and there
are ways to make it tile
across which might be a smart thing to
do if we want our program to look
a little better if we want our squares
to look a little better because
obviously there's one in the center
which is kind of probably small
it's very very stretched so it would
make a lot more sense to actually tile
that
and we can do that but it's going to
take some trial and error
because i'm kind of just guesstimating
on how much i guess we could calculate
how much it's stretched by and then do
some kind of formula
like that to tile it but we can also
just turn it into individual squares but
then we'd have more objects to deal with
in our logic so i don't necessarily want
to do that but for now we're just going
to do
stretch with this whole clamped edge
deal and just a quick note about these
mipmaps these are basically how many
variations it makes
there's a minimum filter and a
magnification filter
so basically it just saves extra
versions of your texture
for when you're far away or when you're
closed depending on how it needs to draw
this is purely an optimization type of
thing
i haven't played around with this a ton
but you can kind of notice differences
once you have a lot of things in your
scene and some distances coming into
play we're not going to worry about
these a whole bunch we're just going to
kind of leave them
like this for now like i said feel free
to look them up if you need to
okay so the most important thing here is
we need to either
configure it with alpha or non-alpha
because if the texture has alpha we want
to use g
opengl's function text 2d just the same
but we want to note it on these two
particular inputs
if it has alpha in this third field here
you need this exact thing rgb8 or a8
on this other one you just need rgba so
you have to know how this text data is
coming in
and set the alpha accordingly that
should handle like
pngs that have alpha and that don't and
we can also use jpeg or whatever as long
as we're getting the data in here and we
know whether it has alpha or not we can
upload it the correct way
you might if you get some errors on
these you've done you've probably just
set one of them wrong because like if
you try to upload
something without alpha to one without
with alpha
you often get errors all right so let's
go into the code that actually calls
this upload texture
so over here in our 2d game under side
scroller i believe we've got it in here
somewhere
now this file is getting to be a little
bit big but it basically encompasses
this entire little 2d game
so it could be abstracted out easily is
the whole point all you're going to do
is just plop it within that loop like we
do in our main here
all right so without getting too
distracted let's continue this old side
scroller we've got a whole name space
for it so we can kind of see where
everything lies there and you know it
might make sense to pull some of this
stuff in there
but one of the things you can see and
this is just temporary is i've got a
text
one id this is going to be the id
that we're uploading so it would
probably be better as an unsigned yet
but we're just going to leave it in but
this
when we call let's see let me just see
where i call it
upload texture when we upload this
texture yeah we're going to save it as
the text one id
that way we can do some other stuff for
it okay so let's just walk through this
setup that's probably going to be the
best way
so we do prepare our aspect ratio thing
same as we were using before
just using that ortho size that way we
can reshape our window and everything
will stay the same
we're going to stick with that method
for now but feel free to play around
with it of course
okay we're doing pretty much the same
thing with our shaders except now our
frag code
is frag textured so since we're going
through this let's go ahead and take a
peek at these shaders because there are
some changes
now the projected is actually exactly
the same uh well actually i'm sorry it's
a little bit different
we've added texture coordinates but
rather than pass in texture coordinates
which we
could we're just going to calculate the
texture coordinates based off the
position
because this is a really simple shape so
we can get away with doing that now
first i was trying this clamp method
which in theory i thought would work
right but what we get is this weird
triangle
uh like so and not a proper whatever
filter it's just
so i couldn't get rid of that using this
clamp method although when i
looked at it and looked at it i couldn't
figure out exactly why it's wrong but it
is
all right so we're going to use this
formula instead where we take the
position
add 1 divided by 2 for the x that's the
x coordinate
and for the y coordinate we're doing 1
minus
position of y plus 1 divided by 2. so
that should accurately get you those
texture coordinates if you're using
the same kind of plane that we're using
here where's our plane there it is it's
just a negative one to one
plane which i've renamed this particular
variable that way
it's easy to find and easy to know
exactly what it is just by its variable
name
but ultimately this is something that we
just upload
and kind of leave in our draw strip
details that's the only thing in our
drawstrip details
this goes way back to earlier episodes
but basically this is prepared to have a
bunch of different objects in it
so we can iterate through it and draw
everything at once right now we still
only have this
one plane in there because that's really
all we need to do all these effects
there's no need to re-upload the same
geometry you could just stick with the
same geometry and reuse it as needed
so let's keep looking at these yeah so
we're doing a texture
coordinate based off that everything
else is the same so let's take a look at
our fragment for textured coordinates
this is basically just like the colored
one except
instead of color we're going to bring in
whatever text
or whatever text coordinates are passed
in from this guy
just right here so in this case we are
going to need a sampler 2d
of a utex of texture now this is
literally just a 2d texture
and this is what we need to set it is a
uniform so we need to set it when you
tell
opengl some things before it will
actually work so those are the two
shaders we're using for this very basic
method here
okay so let's dive back to our side
scroller and continue on and we'll get
to the important parts so some of this
is still the same we make our shader
we check the attributes and we set our
projection matrix
set our view matrix i took the look at
look at off of there because we don't
want to try to do any angles right now
we're just still
sitting at the zero zero position
staring straight down the negative z
axis we're just gonna sit in that
position so
uploading the texture first of all you
need a path to a texture and i do have
one here
uh it's just that brick one i might
change this before i upload it so it
might look a little different once you
got downloaded or whatever from the
source code so
we just need a path so i've saved it to
texture one string called texture1 and
this is a jpeg
it does not have alpha or actually i
think it no it doesn't
so i guess another thing i noticed and
this might kind of contradict what i
said before
but if it does not have alpha you seem
to be able to upload it
as an alpha texture just fine but not
vice versa so if you have something that
does have an alpha and you try to upload
it as a non-alpha it'll bug out but if
you
upload something that does not have an
alpha has an alpha texture it seems fine
it might vary some i'm not entirely sure
that's just something i kind of noticed
in general it's probably going to be
best to just match them in fact let's go
ahead and use this other texture
which is just some displacement from
some other thing and it kind of looks a
little cloudy
but this one actually has an alpha so we
would have to turn the blend on to be
able to see that so i did
at some point i think i had this in
there last episode i did add
a set blend function in our gl settings
this is just something that opengl
sports you can turn blindfold
funk on and enable you basically just
need these
settings if it's on and if you disable
you just turn it off so we can call the
set blend
and we might be able to see through this
texture because it's supposed to be like
smoky there's supposed to be some areas
that are just alpha through
i believe so we're gonna go back to our
side scroller here and i think
we're just gonna call that set blend
actually we might even do it in our
main do we call this let me see blend no
not setting anywhere so let's do this i
guess anywhere we could do this before
our cursor's set up we'll go
set blend there it is and we just need a
boolean
of the status we want it to be on so
we're just going to set true let's go
ahead and hit play see if we get some
some back more background here now i
can't really tell the difference here
but just be aware for the alpha to
actually work
you do have to have that turned on
otherwise alpha is just going to be
darkness so we'll leave that there for
now since we're using alpha textured
stuff and i could go make a texture and
give a better example okay so opening up
[ __ ] here let's make a 512 by 512
and i'm going to add a new layer delete
the old layer and you'll see that this
layer has alpha we look over here
it's grayed out where it says add alpha
and we could remove it but we want it to
be there
so we had it back now we can delete that
we've got an alpha so we could do
something like uh
i don't know let me just do a quick
thing here where i draw on some of it
but not all of it
let's go for this green color so i'm
going to draw on the edges and as you
can see since i'm paint brushing it in
it's somewhat
faded as you can see through it there's
alpha and we'll put a little dot in the
center too
all right so just as a sample file that
definitely has some alpha involved so we
can play around with it let's go ahead
and export this
i guess this time we make a resource
folder i'm going to put it on the roof
resources i'm just going to save this in
there as
demo alpha.png another thing that i
haven't really mentioned that's also
kind of important
is you want these textures these images
to be of a certain size
so if i make one that's like 591 by
whatever it might not load up correctly
you typically want them to be
of a uniform size and something that is
divisible by four that seems to be the
most important thing is it being
divisible by four
i believe that to be true let me know if
you have different findings
okay so now we can tell it to load up
that texture let's go back to our side
scroller to where it loads up our
texture
and let's get rid of these old lines
it's now just going to be
let's just look at this demo alpha real
quick see i see our terrible texture
there it is that's the one we made it's
got the alpha you can see right through
the areas and the areas where it's not
completely filled in
and see it's a little yellowish and
that's because it's blending the green
with the black background if we change
the background that yellowish will
change to whatever new mix it would be
let's just do that real quick i think we
have that in our main
set to this clear color now you'll see
it's kind of a different color
that's because it's blending through
with the background that's the whole
point of alpha you can kind of see
through it's what you want for like
windows and glass and water
and things you can kind of see through
but there's a lot more to it than that
it's just a kind of a quick hack you can
do to texture in a window or something
or water
is you can use this alpha feature on
your image editor
but yeah there you go so let's continue
on through the code
okay so yeah i'll just walk through this
this is pretty common stb
code stb is just an image loader that
someone made
uh it's a library that you will have to
bring in so if you don't have it you
might need it and you need to have
somewhere in your code where
you declare where it's built and for us
we're doing that right here in the
sidescroller.h
obviously it can't build in a dot h file
but we are going with a project setup
where we literally only have one
object file you know you don't
necessarily want to always do this
sometimes you want separate objects but
for the case of demos
all these dot h's are basically getting
piled into this
main so there's only one object so long
story short stb
actually ends up getting built with our
main because that's where the side
scroller stuff builds but in general you
have this in
a cpp file where it builds so enough
about that but
you do need to install that with vc
package manager too if you haven't and
it should just auto work with this repo
okay so we want to win a height at a
comp
now what this comp is i believe stands
for composition
in general we're not going to worry
about it too much sometimes people try
to play around with
oh does it have alpha or not we'll go
off of that but you need to tell
stbi the alpha before you even get this
comp so that doesn't really work you
actually need to know ahead of time
and we don't really end up using this
comp in our case and i'm not sure if we
ever will really but you do need to pass
something there for its set mainly we
need the width and the height
and we need to set this alpha correctly
all right so this basically gives us the
data
from the texture so whatever this
texture was the data for it is now all
saved in this uh carestar so then we
just
upload it using our opengl function
which wants the width the i
the image data and whether it's alpha or
not and it returns the id
this one we already looked at but there
it is real quick
again and you'll see i've already put in
an unload texture for when we're all
done with it
that takes it off the graphics card so
in theory you could build a system where
you upload textures as you need them and
if nothing's using them anymore they
automatically unload if something starts
using them again you can upload them
so you can kind of build your own system
of managing these we're not really going
to do that right now but i do plan on
doing some episodes about organization
there's just so many options that what's
best for my current project is not
necessarily what's best for your current
project so you just have to do some
critical thinking about that
all right so once we upload the texture
we can now free the image data this
basically just deletes the image data
you can keep it if you want
because you can do things like modify it
you can walk through it and process it
we're not going to talk about that
really but it's something you can't do
we're just uploading it as is and go
and going like that keeping it really
simple so once it's uploaded
it's on the graphics card but you're not
actually using it yet so you do have to
use this
texture within your shader and you do
that with the whole
set and we'll see that here so let's
collapse the setup
okay so where we're actually doing all
that setting of the textures is in our
render
so in the render for our site scroller
first we say okay let's use the shader
and then we're going to do this texture
thing now this is kind of hacked in here
oftentimes you want your
texture settings to be saved with
whatever object that way you can iterate
through them but for now we're just
hacking it and just doing one at a time
we're going to say
the active texture is texture zero which
is the default one
quick side note here sometimes people
set texture zero as some kind of debug
texture like a bright red texture that
way they can tell when they've missed
texture on their object because it's
bright red and
they know they need to go fix it but for
now our texture 0 is the only one we're
using we don't have a debug one
but just fyi that's something people
seem to frequently do when they're
actually building a game and have
multiple people working on it because
you want to know if something gets
messed up in the final version it's like
oh that bright red area right there that
didn't get textured properly it's
setting to texture zero because you
always set back to texture zero when
you're all done
with your processing whatever all right
let's keep walking through this
use texture we activate the texture we
want in this case it's the first one
since we're just playing around then we
bind the texture this is the most
important part
after you activate the texture you want
you then bind it
as the right type gel texture 2d and
then you give it the id
of what whatever one on the graphics
card so we've been saving it as this
so not only do we act we well use the
right shader
activate then bind and then
i guess we don't necessarily need to do
this whole use thing until we're
actually going to call this set end
so this would be more proper but i like
having to use right at the top because
it's the one we're using
i don't know it doesn't really matter i
guess all right you want to set your
uniform
to zero this isn't the texture id this
is
i believe the active texture let me
double check on that okay
yes that is correct you want to set
whatever and you're citing
the same as this active texture so keep
that in mind i guess we could do
something like
now this is fine because usually what
you end up doing as you iterate
through whatever it is however many
textures as you generally are going
through a for loop
and you're adding your for loop to this
and you're setting this
like so but we only have one texture
this is for
the case if you're you want to go
through multiple textures and set them
if your object has like you know
multiple textures
i can't think of the right word for it
right now but basically if you've got
like a whole pvr set up in multiple
textures
you might be doing might be iterating
through rather than just setting texture
zero
or if you just have a particular object
that has multiple
textures like one side is different than
the other is the way you do it
another thing there is that we're not
talking about that deserves this whole
separate episode
is sprite sheets and that's basically
where you have one giant texture and you
just take
sections of it at a time to put on your
objects and texture them
we're just using the whole thing for
right now but we will talk about sprite
sheets
at some point sprite sheets are very
popular for things like 2d animations
because you can section it off as each
part is part of the animation
and just go through that different set
of textures for
whatever your object is and it'll look
like it's animating based on
the animations built into your textures
so it's often just how 2d textures
are done that way you can use just one
square or one plane
and just change the texture on it to
make it look like it's going through
movements
okay well i think that does pretty much
cover it as you can see through the rest
of this
switch where we're drawing it's
basically the same as before
obviously we're not setting the color
anymore that would error out because
we're not using that shader
instead we're just setting everything to
this one texture
but ideally you know everything's going
to have a different texture so
what we probably actually want to do is
expand our objects to hold texture ids
and we can upload different texture ids
form
or things like that all right well i
think that's beyond the scope of this
particular episode it's already getting
a bit long
so we're going to leave this as it is
and go ahead and upload it but this is a
nice
hacky way well i guess it's semi hacky i
think i've covered enough for you to
expand if you want to
basically this is a really nice way to
just be able to
use a texture based on the same plane
we've been rendering all our effects to
previously
and eventually we will get into using 3d
objects
i think i'm just kind of sticking with
2d because it's easier to cover
the root concepts but these translate to
3d basically the same way
i don't want to get too ahead of myself
alright that's going to do it for this
episode guys
thanks for watching hope you uh have
some more insights about texturing and
can kind of generally
figure out how to texture your objects
special shout out to the patrons from
this month i'll put them up on the
screen
there's still time to sign up for next
month if you want to get your name on
the screen and
provide support for me for all the
videos next month it does mean a lot and
really does help me keep producing these
and just thanks to everyone watching
appreciate anyone that watches
viewtime always helps this channel grow
as do likes and subscribes so feel free
all right guess what's going to do it
out hope you have a good day
[Music]
you